Are EMFs worse for kids? What can we do to protect our kids?
Well, certainly there isn't any studies on this kind of stuff because the kids who studies
have kids, but we do think that the same EMFs that are affecting us adults negatively
would probably affect a smaller body in a worse case, especially in developing brain,
developing nervous system would have a greater degree of effect than them.
There's a limited amount of things that you could do to prevent EMFs.
I always suggest that people turn off their Wi-Fi at night.
I think we discussed a few of these things a few weeks ago, and somebody asked a EMF question.
I use a little device called a heat run on my phone.
I also use a phone case that box EMFs, and I very rarely put my phone up to my ear.
I always put it on speakerphone. I also use headphones like this.
These are our air tube headphones. These are the ones that we sell at our store.
It has these little tubes here.
The cell is carried through the air on these. They're basically zero EMF headphones.
We sell a lot of these two pairs with kids because many kids are on pads and computers and listening to things.
The worst thing you could do is have a Bluetooth device in your ear.
Putting your cell phones up to your head is not good for you because you have those EMFs coming from you.
Take a step back and where are we getting EMFs?
Well, I'm getting the US from this computer here, but if you had an EMF device, measuring device,
you could actually measure how much EMFs that computer produces.
It doesn't produce a lot of EMFs, so I'm not really concerned about that.
I actually have a heat rod on my computer right here, out of the corner also.
The other source of EMFs are worse is your cell phones.
The external EMFs from devices that we're using are EMFs that are your electrical box on the outside of your house.
Your cell phone towers are the worst culprit.
There are some things besides moving, but if you live with your cell phone towers, what are you going to do?
Certainly, there are some things like using air-tooth headphones, highly advisable, all like great kids use air-tooth headphones.
Very good when they're listening to things, so very helpful.